now tonight more disgusting basilic
smears against african american
conservatives as a new column by far
left columnist ellie mistahl is entitled
quote the herschel walker senate
campaign is an insult to black people
calling the walker campaign a quote
political minstrel show
now of course this is just another
attempt to smear slander besmirch and
attack a campaign that has built massive
momentum in the state of georgia
and running on an america first make
america great again
agenda remember all the knives are out
for herschel like any other conservative
and recently biden fired walker from the
president's council on health fitness
and nutrition why because democrats uh
you think that's the least political
position they're in desperation mode as
the biden agenda is failing on every
front ahead of the 2022 midterms so all
they got left is smear slander besmirch
attack lie all the above here with
reaction georgia senate candidate
herschel walker
you know
i i find this happens to
african-american conservatives so often
i would like to say that i'm shocked but
i'm not
uh why do you think this exists because
in this world world to the left you you
can't talk this way about people but the
there are exceptions if you're a
conservative especially an
african-american conservative
well you're 100 correct
they're going to do this here and i know
what i signed up for him and i decided
to run but what's strange about it is
he's not telling everyone that the
democratic party has left uh the brown
and black people behind they forgot all
about us and they not just forgot about
us you look at the policies that's going
on which has nothing to do with color
what it has to do with is these policies
is not suitable for the people of
georgia they're not suitable for the
people of the united states of america
and it doesn't matter what he called me
you know i was bullied when i was a
little kid words are not going to hurt
me
right now he knows and i'm going to take
my athletic world out of this i'm the
most qualified candidate for this race
right now and i'm the most qualified
candidate to represent georgia as a
united states senator so it doesn't
matter what you say i know what i've
done you know first of all i did
graduate as one of the top members in my
class in high school and i do have one
of the largest minority owned food
service companies in the united states
of america because i worked my tail off
to become that and i want everyone to
have the same advantages that i've had
and the way you do that is by working
hard by getting out there putting their
perspiration and aspiration to whatever
you do make sure you do it the right way
and so it doesn't matter what they say i
represent the people of georgia and i'm
not going to do what people tell me to
do and i'm not going to have you to
bully me because you can't but what i
would love to do for you to take the
time to come down to georgia we sit down
and break bread because i'm about
bringing people together not separating
people what it seems like you are is it
separate people because of color that's
not herschel walker so you're actually
inviting this author to come and and and
sit down and meet the real herschel
walker and then make your mind up that's
a pretty generous
uh i mean it's holy week so i guess
that's a pretty generous gesture on your
part i i doubt i would be as generous
but what did you make when you and dr oz
both got kicked off the
uh health fitness and nutrition council
it's a volunteer position you've been
appointed to the position you're not
paid for it but you did it because you
want to help the country
uh why are we politicizing that
well that's what's so sad why are you
politicizing that because first of all
i've been working with kids my whole
life i was overweight as a kid i had a
speech impediment i didn't feel good
about myself so i wanted to go out and
help other kids to come up and show them
about working out but also i want to be
proactive rather than reactive what i
mean by that is you know exercise
sometimes helps you through a lot of
things that can help you in life through
your health care it can help you with
you know most people my color you know
we have problems we have a problem with
our weight so i wanted to help kids that
have a weight problem i'm gonna help
kids and let them know they can become
just like herschel walker they can
become a herschel walker even better
than a herschel walker so i wanted to
encourage kids so they kicked me off
because of some partisan issue that they
have with me and i'm saying that's okay
it's not going to stop me it's not going
to stop me i'm going to continue to do
the work for the kids because that's
what i'm doing right now i'm going to
fight for this country i'm going to
fight for the state of georgia i'm going
to fight for all the kids in the in the
state of georgia i'm going to fight for
all the kids in the united states of
america i'm going to fight for the women
right now i want people to know i do not
believe men should be in women's sports
i don't the definition of a woman is
written in the bible it said man and
woman i know that and i'm going to fight
for the women as well
let me ask you you know before i endorse
the candidate and i've talked about this
before i really want to know where you
stand on issues and before you announce
that you're going to make this run we
had a number of discussions leading up
to it
and you gave me a pretty phenomenal
answer i don't know if you remember the
specific question but i but i did ask
you
tell me
how you describe yourself politically
and i'll throw that question at you so
people can understand where you're
coming from better
well where i stand is i stand for
america that means that i stand for the
constitution i'm pro-police i'm
pro-military i'm pro-education and all
those things that say hershey you're a
conservative i'm a conservative why
because i want the things that this
country has fought for and people have
died for the freedom the liberties and
freedoms that this country has given me
the freedom and liberty that they've
given every per every legal american out
there that they have those freedoms and
those uh liberties to go out and work to
become whatever they want to become that
america's dream you know it's amazing
because you're the antithesis you know
we have record high inflation out of
control record high gas prices rafael
warnock has gone along with every single
radical policy of joe biden
this is going to be
one of the most important races in the
country we're going to watch it closely
we always appreciate you coming on
herschel walker thank you for being with
us
well thank you so much and i want
everyone out there to know to go to
teamrehearsal.com because let's remove
this thought out of everyone's mind and
know that we're all american let's come
together and put herschel walk in that
seat
all right thank you hershel walker hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else